i am so happy to be here thank you so
much to the organizers for the
invitation and all of you attending it
is really amazing to be able to
participate
i am especially grateful that i could do
this remotely as there was still a lot
of uncertainty around traveling with the
pandemic when i accepted the invitation
this talk is a collection of thoughts
and conversations that i've had over the
past few years
and i'm really looking forward to
hearing what other people have to say as
well
it's possible that many of the things
i'll mention here are obvious to you
and it is also possible that this is the
first time you're thinking about it
either way i'd love to hear from you and
get this conversation going
a lot of the things that i'll say come
from my experience in open source
projects
but that doesn't mean that it can't also
be applied in other contexts so i am
especially curious to hear your thoughts
on applying the same ideas to other
kinds of projects
so my name is melissa i am based in
brazil where i'm originally from and i
work as a software engineer at quansite
my work focuses on open source projects
such as numpy and sci-fi
and although i don't like talking about
myself too much i'd like to give you
some context as to how i got here
in 2019 i went to the sci-fi conference
in person in austin texas
this is the picture that you're seeing
right now
although it had been around open source
and python for a while mainly doing
talks outreach education
and participating in meetups in brazil
i was working as a professor of
mathematics at the federal university of
santa catarina in the south of brazil
my work focused on numerical
optimization and i had made the switch
from matlab to python a few years prior
and i wanted to get involved with the
scientific python community
i was unhappy at the university and the
whole research thing
and i was looking for a career change
i got funding to go to sci-fi in person
and ended up joining the numpy and
sci-fi sprint
and met ralph gummers who is in the
picture next to me
who at the time was recruiting for
quansite
so the picture you see here is my first
code contribution to open source
and six months later i ended up joining
quanside and leaving academia behind
so this is a reminder that although i do
understand that is it it is extremely
hard and
hard work and very complicated
i am eternally grateful that there are
conferences still offering remote
possibilities at this stage
it is very clear that in the last couple
of years a lot of people from the global
south have been able to participate
and take part in conversations
and in conferences and opportunities
that they would not have otherwise
either because it's hard to travel
because of funding or because of visa
restrictions or more recently because of
vaccination passport restrictions
it is clear that participating and this
kind of event
opens up a lot of professional
possibilities
so
again a reminder that if you can
and if there is a way please continue
offering remote possibilities for
conferences
now why am i here today
well i'm sure you've seen thought or
heard this before
there's a diversity problem in open
source
what does this mean
it means that open source is largely
white
from the global north and male
a lot of people much more informed and
experienced than me have tried to
explain the reasons behind this
and i'm not sure i can contribute much
to that conversation
except to say that there are more things
involved than we as individuals or even
as projects can control
society cultures institutional racism
sexism and xenophobia the inequality of
access to technologies hardware
internet access information language
barriers the list goes on and on
does this mean we should just give up
i don't think so
but we need to understand what we're
talking about when we say there's a
problem in open source
the linux foundation has elaborated a
report on diversity equity and inclusion
and open source in 2021
and in there they define diversity as
follows
we define diversity within open source
communities as a pluralism of any number
of the following possibilities
gender identity and expression
race ethnicity
sexual orientation age
social class
case
language physical and neurological
ability and attributes
religious beliefs
value systems
national origin and political
affiliation
that's a mouthful
and even in this definition we don't
have a complete agreement
the definition changes
words change the way we call things
change
the first thing we need to understand is
that diversity is and always will be a
moving target
again this is not an excuse for not
working on improving
rather this is an acknowledgement that
this work is never done
and that we should have a learning
mindset be prepared to listen and change
our minds frequently
now in this map
it doesn't actually represent the data
but it gives you an idea of the
distribution of people working on open
source
at least considering the linux
foundation report from last year
north america and europe accounted for
36 percent of survey respondents each
15 of the respondents were from the asia
pacific region
eight percent from central and south
america
and five percent from the middle east
middle east and africa
open source is a heavily skewed towards
the global north
this is partially to be expected as
internet and technological
infrastructure is also concentrated in
these areas
but we must keep in mind whenever we
talk about global open source projects
but this is not actually true
of course there are also many other
variables here
while 81 of people surveyed in this
linux foundation survey can read and
write english well there are others for
whom language presents a barrier to
participation or belonging in open
source communities
so based on this data and this map
should we conclude that people in the
global south are just not interested in
open source
i don't think so
there are clearly explicit and implicit
barriers that prevent
people from the global south from
joining open source projects
and this is also clearly true for other
minoritized groups
keep in mind that these may be invisible
to you because of your position in the
world
this is a complex problem and i don't
believe in a simple solution
however even if we can't eliminate the
factors that come from society or
structures that we can't control
there is clearly room for improvement
i'm not an expert here
however i don't believe only experts
should be talking about this
we need to have these conversations more
frequently and try things more often
i have learned to speak from my own
experience and not that of others so
this is what i'll say
in my experience i believe that there
are at least three areas we can address
right now
that would actually improve the
situation
first is the fact that we are relying at
least partially on invisible labor
and i will explain that shortly
second is that the way we organize our
projects internally
and how this can end up being an
extension of the existing power
structures around us can create problems
and third the way we consciously or
unconsciously fit people into
stereotypes
and end up limiting their possibilities
first let's talk about who is working on
open source
if we look at the linux foundation
survey again
of the survey respondents only 14 get
paid for their open source contributions
and all of them mentioned that time is
the number one determinant for
participation in open source
things like time zones unpaid time and
onboarding time factor into when or how
people can participate
it's no secret that open source relies
on volunteer work
and this is not bad at all and many
other areas of our lives may depend on
volunteer work
however we must keep in mind that this
does limit who gets to participate
we are relying on people spending their
free time on this
who has free time on their hands
women people of color and other
minoritized groups are
disproportionately responsible for
caring for children or relatives doing
housework or being in a position to
spend several hours commuting
for example
how can we expect this game to be fair
if the number one determinant for
participation can't be met
there is also a widespread belief in
meritocracy and that you only really
learn things by doing them the hard way
i have suffered to learn this you need
to suffer as well
it's the read the manual attitude
when you pair this with the lack of free
time you have a recipe for exclusion
but there's yet another point to be made
here
not all contributions are visible
on github or any other
issue tracker or website that you use to
track work on open source projects
answering questions on slack or email
organizing surveys
meetings social media and all other
kinds of glue work don't get you green
squares on github
and they end up being erased from
project metrics
but
at least once you join everyone is the
same right
well many of our projects have internal
hierarchies
for example opposing code and non-code
contributions
core developers being the highest point
you can reach in a project over all
kinds of contributions
behind this all are welcome message
there's an unspoken expectation and
rules
including cultural rules such as slang
acronyms
jargon expected tone of interactions
and there's personal rules
for example people from academia may
have different expectations about
working in collaboration with others
than people in industry
governance for projects is not always
explicit and clear
how does one get to be a core developer
do you have a process for someone to
step down from your project
how long does someone need to contribute
to be able to make decisions and be
considered leadership for the project
there's an article that many people cite
when talking about open source
called the tyranny of structurelessness
by joe freeman
this essay
that is inspired by her experiences in
the 60s when she worked in a feminist
group
talks about how an informal
unacknowledged and unaccountable
leadership
arises
when there is no defined hierarchy in a
group
freeman in this essay suggests
formalizing the existing hierarchies in
the group
and subjecting them to democratic
control to prevent that
i believe this can be at least in part
applied to open source projects
organizational structures
now often when you mention improving
diversity in open source projects
you will hear things such as yes let's
create more documentation issues
or no this will lower the bar for a
project
and this is something i've heard before
this shows how the power structures that
i was mentioning before
are translated into stereotypes
and people are immediately expected to
conform to these positions
we could talk about gendered work just
as an example
but there are many other aspects of this
including how people who are less
proficient in english can be seen by
native speakers as less experienced or
less knowledgeable
all of this can severely limit the
possibilities for contribution and
growth inside a project
this can also mean that the weight of
doing hard and unrecognized glue work
that i mentioned earlier
falls completely on the shoulders of
people from underrepresented groups
when they join a project they may be
immediately sent to do work that will
never give them enough credit to move
over to leadership positions in the
future
we need to be proactive about both
things not enforcing stereotypes and
making sure that all contributions
receive credit and recognition
well this is terrible right there are so
many problems how can we possibly
improve this
this is not something we can solve
overnight we need strategy we need more
research
and we definitely need need to talk
about what's hard about this work
i do believe that a lot of progress has
been made
which is why i named this talk beyond
the basics
many people in projects are in fact
doing the basics they have codes of
conduct they have contribution
guidelines they have good first issue
labels on github and they have
governance documentation
but we need to keep pushing forward
so
now that we know more or less how things
are
what can we do
i want to propose this
comparison of where we are now and where
we want to be
what we have now is that many projects
are using codes of conduct
they are improving and using inclusive
language
they are trying to set up clear
governance for their projects
but this is more of a passive stance
in which you have your project you kind
of make things work inside of it but you
don't actively bring new people in
where we want to be is actually push for
culture change
we want to question our assumptions
about what's working in our own projects
and we want to investigate new and fair
metrics we want to be more active about
how we improve the situation and what we
can do inside our own projects
so like i said i am no expert but i do
have a few proposals of things that we
can invest time and resources in
first
i am a big believer in mentorship
mentorship is often very effective and
can be powerful when it comes to
changing culture
through mentorship and creating this
individual connection between a
maintainer or an experienced contributor
and a newcomer
you can really create pathways and
encourage people and make them feel
empowered to develop their own selves
inside the project
like i said before
setting clear expectations and
developing trust in processes
for governance
ensures sustainability for the project
mentorship is great but we don't just
want to have new contributors we want to
have new maintainers and we want to have
new leaders
this is what will help us get
sustainability
unless we can set up a pathway for new
leaders our projects are going to die
now we need to also encourage curiosity
we need to create a safe and welcoming
environment for people of all
backgrounds and experience levels to
approach our project
that's the only way that we can cast a
wide enough net
to get people to contribute and create
diverse cultures inside our projects
and for that we also need to improve our
contribution pathways
providing a better distribution of work
and celebrating different kinds of
contributions is extremely important to
diversify
roles inside the project and the people
who will approach the project in the
first place
now how can we do this
we have been working for a while in the
concept of contributor experience
let's say that this is a dedicated
effort to onboarding retention and a
focus on diversifying contribution
pathways
this particular work is being developed
through a grant
that we have received from the chen
zuckerberg initiative
to work on numpy scipy matplotlib and
pandas so this is a cross project grant
this is a two-year project and like i
said before this is not meant to be a
simple solution to a complex problem
but rather an attempt to make progress
or find out that it doesn't work but i
hope not
this is especially about making
volunteer contributor work easier
and it is also about cross-project
analysis
there are many differences between
projects and we hope we can not only
identify these differences but
understand the high level winds that
other projects downstream can also learn
from
so a little bit more about what is
contributor experience
when we talk about attracting and
onboarding first-time contributors what
do we want to do with those first-time
contributors
if we look at the state of the octavers
report from this year
the number of first-time contributors to
open source projects is growing year
over year
so
there is no shortage of first-time
contributors what we want to do is work
on retention
providing individual support such as
mentoring encouragement empowerment
and making sure that they have a way in
to the project
another way to improve that process
is to create scaffolded contributions
what do we mean by that
if a task
a big project takes a long time for a
first time contributor to understand
what they even have to do there
or to finish that project
they may be
less enthusiastic about starting to work
in the first place
creating smaller slices of tasks that
people can pick up and work
in smaller amounts of time
may create more opportunities for
contribution for example
another example is by having pair
programming sessions
along with their mentors or some other
people contributors in the community who
can help
for this we mentioned individual support
but we also want to create a network of
collaboration for scale and
sustainability
again we want new maintainers not just
new contributors
so we are working on creating newcomer
spaces
and not reliant on one single point of
failure for each project or for each
contribution that newcomers can make
we want to make sure that people have
different paths to contribution but also
different means of communication
so in addition to github having meetings
forums slack other points of
communication that you can use or
monitor
can be helpful
this is hard work so
we need to be careful not to overdo it
but it does create a sense of connection
and community and gives people the
opportunity to not be constrained by
conversation over text which is
notoriously difficult to get right
now
how can we know that this is actually
improving something
well metrics are hard
like i said the number of first-time
contributors to github repositories
continues to grow
but is this actually measuring health
or are more of the same kind of people
joining
demographic data is not easy to come by
or to interpret if all you have is data
from github
this is not representative of diversity
in your community
when we look at the linux foundation
survey
82 of survey respondents feel welcome in
open source
but when you look at demographic
segmentations you see varied sentiments
people who do not feel welcome in open
source
are disproportionately from
underrepresented groups
so we need to be very careful about
metrics
belonging inclusion and barriers can be
subjective and contextual
we only measure what is easy to measure
as a teacher i came to understand that
exams and tests don't really assess
knowledge or ability to solve problems
they assess what is easy to grade
these metrics are similar we're only
looking for the key that we lost where
the lamp is we must be transparent about
what we're not measuring
so maybe we need to invest in exit
surveys or follow up individual
interviews
in any case we need better
infrastructure to have better metrics
now a few more things that we can
consider
first
we need to make sure that we are
transparent we need to admit that we
have a problem
hiding things or throwing them under the
rug is not going to solve the problem
we want to be inclusive
this means listening and working with
the people that are historically
marginalized
and not imagining what the ideal
solution would be
we need to be active and supporting and
recognizing the work of others
there is this concept of sponsorship
which is extremely powerful
when we talk about diversity equity and
inclusion
we want to make sure that people from
underrepresented groups feel supported
and feel recognized in the work that
they do
we want to create safe environments so
code of conduct enforcement and having a
plan
in advance for when something happens
is extremely important
problems will happen
that's life
we need to be able to have a plan for
when something happens we know what to
do
now we also need to admit
our vulnerability
we are not perfect and we need to be
open to criticism and feedback
this is the only way we can actually
learn something is by listening to
others and understanding that when we
make mistakes we apologize
and we move on
by accepting
criticism and by doing things better
next time this is the only way we can
improve as a community
and finally we need to be brave and have
courage
as groups grow they need to deal and
learn from conflict
this is a known factor in large groups
the only groups where you will see zero
conflict are the ones made up of people
very similar to each other and that's
exactly what we don't want
okay so these are the soft skills
this is so hard there's so many things
to think about
now let's remember we're all beginners
be curious and educate yourself
you can read listen watch
do your research there's an incredible
amount of content out there and it
doesn't even have to be about dei
talk
and listen to people who are different
from you who come from a different
background who speak a different
language or who live in a different
country
understanding other people's experiences
and learning from them is what the
internet is for
we have this opportunity and it is
extremely important that we remember
this
finally remember
behind the screen there are people
people have different motivations for
contributing and they are all valid they
don't have to be the same as yours
we can absolutely create human
connection over an open source projects
and this is good
this is not just about software software
does not exist on a void
it is very much about people and the
richness of human experience
finally remember to be compassionate
recognize our shared humanity
genuine curiosity about other people's
experiences
can go a long way towards creating a
healthy environment in your open source
project
this is what i had to say and i am again
extremely thankful to be here
i'll take any questions that you have
and i would be extremely happy to follow
up here or later on social media over
email and i'll i would be extremely
happy to hear what you think can be done
for this
thank you
[Applause]
thank you minnesota
[Applause]
thank you melissa for joining us from
brazil
um i'm alex i'm your session chair you
probably saw the live stream
so i'm going to read the audience
questions from slido to you and the most
popular question is i'm just going to
read them
this is very nice but in reality 90 of
the open source project contributors
come from professional teams and
companies
how do you ensure diversity then
well i think there are several things to
unpack there one is
obviously there is a big problem with
hiring and recruiting and outreach and
creating a safe environment and
companies for people to contribute
we also know that even in the companies
that have
people working professionally with open
source this is usually a small amount of
time or something that they're expected
to do in addition to their um
let's say official work and so it ends
up being again some sort of privilege to
be able to work on open source
so i do think that companies have as
i've said in the talk companies have to
be active about enabling this and making
sure people have access and can actually
participate and contribute
and i do believe that this is something
that we need to ask for and and
advocate for in the companies and i know
it's not easy i know that big companies
and this is a huge problem for open
source pro projects in general which is
that the larger companies uh that
actually
benefit from the development of open
source don't really contribute that much
and so this is something that we
actually have to advocate for it's more
support
more time
more
options for people to contribute to open
source and then inside the companies
there's also a culture change that needs
to happen for this to to
improve
thank you
next question
we've got a few
but it's all right we have 10 minutes 12
minutes left and there's a break so no
need to rush
next question imposter syndrome tends to
be more common among minorities do you
have any recommendations on how to deal
with it when starting to contribute to
open source
that's a tough question because i'm
actually feeling a lot of imposter
syndrome right now talking to you and so
i do think that this is something that's
very common and i would say the best
strategy that i found for myself
in my experience is to get together with
other people who are just getting
started
creating networks of newcomers or
creating networks of people who are
contributing at the same experience
level as you
and those connections and being able to
help each other and talk to each other
and share your experiences tends to help
a lot and so that's the number one
recommendation that i would make of
course i also think that having mentors
and having the feeling safe enough to
ask questions
also helps because you feel like people
are actually listening to you and
they value your experience whatever it
is
um
and then there's something else that i
think leadership can do to improve uh
the situation for people who are feeling
imposter syndrome which is
putting yourself forward and asking the
questions that you think the newcomers
have
um if you ask those questions they will
feel well it's not just me that has this
question you know um
other people feel it too i'm not alone
and and so this is
there's a lot of things that leadership
can do to improve the situation and one
of them is put yourself forward ask the
questions be able to you know create a
safe environment for questions and for
people who are just joining
thank you
the next question
in your experience how would open source
project benefit from more diversity
well i think there's several um
i think
first of all i do believe that open
source is meant to be
benefiting everyone and if you are
looking to benefit everyone everyone
needs to be involved how can you create
a solution that is supposed to be
universal if the people who are
developing it are coming from a small
group of people and so i do think that
having diversity in your teams improve
the quality of the project
but in the larger sense i just think
it's the right thing to do making sure
that people have access that they can
actually like if they want to come to
your project that they feel safe enough
to do so i think that's just basic um
understanding of how people work
we should be welcoming we should be
providing this to people if they
cannot join because of barriers that we
can actually remove
it would be wrong not to remove them and
so i think it's just um
of course there's the question of
quality which i deeply believe in i
think diverse teams do better projects
but i also think it's just the right
thing to do from an ethical point of
view is allowing people to be able to
access to be able to participate to feel
safe enough so that they can give their
own input to the project
thank you
the next question
[Music]
should this talk not stop with the
question how to attract more
contributors
why mixing the whole topic with
diversity and racism
okay so i think the question of bringing
more people
is
who are we bringing like i said in the
beginning there is no shortage of new
contributors they are joining the
project
the question is where they're coming
from what is their experience and what
do they bring to the project and so we
want to have everyone we want to be able
to bring people from all sorts of
backgrounds all sorts of geographical
locations all sorts of national origins
and
so if we are
consistently bringing 90 of people from
the global north
something is weird there and so
we need to put more effort where we have
more
trouble let's say where we have more
difficulty bringing people in so i do
believe that this is important that we
need to question ourselves about why
this is happening and that we need to
put an effort to understand uh
why this happens so this is fact that
people are coming more from global north
and their people are coming more from
the united states and europe
and so i do believe that we need to
open doors and and invite everyone in
right thank you
the next question
uh i'm just going to read this one okay
please stop voting because it's
i
it's uh after fall i have to keep track
so um this one
uh
after a numpy paper with an exclusively
male author list was released the
student tweeted the p and numpai stands
for patriarchy what's your take on that
thank you for the question um
so i think this is a very
this is i can say this this is a very
stressful moment for all of us i was
working in the project for about
i don't know maybe eight months and it
was really interesting to see
how social media took a completely
different um
take on whatever happened and so
yes
that was
there was
um how can i say legitimate and fair
criticism that the paper had an all male
author list however we did go through
like me and other women who were working
in the project for example we had a lot
of abuse and people online
sending direct messages and threatening
us and kind of doing a bunch of
things that we did not want to happen
obviously um
and i do think that we need to be
careful about the social media and how
we deal with those things and how these
pylons happen and so
i believe that in the end the end result
was positive uh we ended up
you know this this uh ended up sparking
a whole conversation inside the project
and inside other projects as well about
how we can improve this for the future
how we don't want this to happen again
and so the net result is positive which
i think is great um and so that's what
i'm trying to focus on is how can we
move forward like i said in the talk we
need to listen to criticism we need to
accept this um and be humble about
understanding what we're doing wrong and
improving for the future and this is
what we're trying to do we're trying to
address this problem and we're trying to
do the best that we can so that this
doesn't happen again
lessons learned thank you
how do you deal with the mix of pro and
active actual volunteers how do you make
decisions when some are working and
others are volunteering
yeah i think this is a very
important question and something that we
try to do
um with numpy and scipy is
having a strong governance model that
includes people both from professional
and volunteer points of view and that we
enable everyone to have a voice and so
my own particular understanding is that
people who are professionally working in
open source should make work easier for
the volunteers and so that's the basics
that we we stand on which is
doing the heavy lifting doing the you
know boring work
ci taking care of things that volunteers
don't usually pick up and so that's how
we started working on the documentation
and and creating the documentation team
because a lot of people they want to do
new features they want to work on code
and they want to start contributing to
get their names um
you know as contributors to numpy and
usually they don't want to do the heavy
lifting of reorganizing documentation
and things like that and so
if you do have the ability to have
professionals uh working on your open
source project and you can have money
for that and you can have
people who are paid to do that
pick up the things that are not usually
done by volunteers that's where you
should be spending your money on so that
you can have a well-rounded project
supported by all sides
that's what i believe in i do think it's
a delicate problem and that we need to
put that explicit and governance which
is not to
let
companies
take over the project or decide
everything for the project if you want
to have volunteer contributions you need
to include them in decision making as
well
yeah thank you with three more questions
how can we encourage women and mothers
especially to contribute more
this is an um interesting question for
me i'm a mom as well um i do think that
this is
hard but we need to
make sure that we have
the support that people need and this is
not only for mothers there are people
who take care of their
relatives they have elderly people that
they need to take care of and there's
all sorts of situations that
could could be looked at
kind of the same way
i think that giving people expectation
setting
expectations so that they know how they
can contribute how much time they'll
spend in each task how much time are
they expected to spend every week so
that they can plan ahead
if you're doing uh events if you're
doing in-person meetups that you have a
space for children or that you have a
way for people to
care for children or
i don't know that you have child care a
lot of meetups and groups are already
doing that i think it's super important
but more than that i think it's enabling
people to do work on their own rhythm
and so not expecting that they'll answer
right away or
enabling them to do smaller tasks at a
time so that they can pick up this pro
these projects and plan ahead with the
time that they have
um
at least that's what i see from my
experience my biggest difficulty being a
mother is finding the free time usually
when you have any free time you're
spending with your family and so being
able to pick up one hour here one hour
there
is just
amazing and that's when you can do
actual work if you have to spend five
hours reading the manual to be able to
start then that's harder and so
having these smaller tasks and enabling
people to have different entry points
into the project
might help
thank you
for maintainers managing the project is
a huge task how can they focus on
diversity alongside without burning out
yes so i do think that this is something
that asks a lot of the maintainers and
which is why
it
usually
we have maintainers doing everything in
a project it's very hard to have
specialization so
the same people who are reviewing code
they're writing documentation and
organizing community are doing all of
this kind of work together um
one possibility is to have people who
are focused exclusively on community and
improving diversity or contributor
experience and doing that
focusing on that so they don't have to
split themselves between several tasks
and i know this is not easy for smaller
projects
so what i would say is do what you can
you don't have to do everything at once
because i do understand that this is a
big ask and i do understand that this is
hard on
especially volunteer maintainers
especially if you have a an open source
project that is not professionally
maintained and so do what you can start
small start with what you can do
um
but yeah consider doing separating these
tasks or at least writing them up for
one example is that we don't usually
put community uh tasks as issues but
maybe you could maybe you could be very
explicit about what you want to achieve
in terms of community and other people
can come and help you with that it
doesn't have to be one person doing
everything
but for that you need to be able to
delegate you need to be able to organize
these tasks and what you see for the
vision for your project
so that's what i would recommend for
smaller projects and i would love to
hear from you as well if you have
suggestions if you have ideas if you
have experience with that i would love
to hear
thank you last question
what do conferences add to or the open
source ecosystem
where are conferences good what could
conference organizers do better in the
future
well one thing that i noted and that i i
also know it's a big ask i know it's
hard and you folks must be experiencing
this right now but doing um enabling a
remote participation model i think is
really important and uh
does allow a lot more people to
participate we saw this um
in brazil we have our local pycon we
call it python brazil and the last two
years where we were remote we were 100
remote
there was just so many people joining
and we can feel
how many people would never be able to
join if it was in prison because they
would have to travel brazil is a huge
country
and so
wherever you choose to do your
conference people will not be able to go
we have had also great experience in
brazil with having crowdfunding for pie
ladies so that they could go to the
conference and we've seen a huge
improvement in attendance just by having
that working
another thing like i said before child
care options those are usually uh
you know super important for people who
have children who need to to take them
with them um who will be attending need
a room for breastfeeding need a room for
a
naps and all of that infrastructure
necessary for a child
um
but again i know that it can be
complicated and that it can be hard and
costly it costs money
so i guess it depends on the
possibilities that you have for your
conference
another thing which is something that
i'm not the first person to say but i
will say it anyway is to be active when
you're searching for speakers when
you're looking for your keynotes when
you're looking for people who are going
to present at the conference be active
about not just looking
in in one place for your speakers search
widely
go look at other places go ask people
about
different topics different people people
from different countries people from
different origins that can come and
speak at your conference that's the
moment where you can actually connect
and talk to people who have different
experiences from you so
that that's when you can take advantage
of that
thank you very much i think if you were
here i think we could continue for one
two three more
hours unfortunately
we have a schedule
i will thank you very much from for
joining us from brazil
we all hope to meet you in person
somewhere around the world soon thank
you very much melissa for joining us
[Applause]